Tiffany Simon's steps in down to go to
the three guard and back door here he
come then it comes to Scylla BC air
scout
solid streets at her Springs Jane 101 on
Jared Allen averages one point three
blocks the game is very long 16 the
games stay operating oh boy an on-call
Terry Stotts is stopped and man
Irving knocks it down
twice side trying to spring Dave goes
right at Al and beat him to the punch to
lay at home
[Applause]
Simon Says the assignment of Kyrie
behind the back pain
it's not bad defensive effort
got Alan on the switch up top flurry of
ball moves between the wickets step back
and watch that three that contact then
dissonant look at the footwork okay so
I'm talking about that step back at the
end surveys the scene he's got five he's
got four he works on dimwitty step back
a three got it
Damian Lunt where the triple four tenths
of a second remaining for the next
halfway through the threat of the dried
gets you running towards the ramp from
fire Whiteside who is 10 for the night
big wide-open break he'll like its
weight in it might be one of those kind
of nights close game going down the
stretch he weighs 265 loaded into the
lane Bulldog is just acting up this this
doesn't make any sense
I'm not even gonna try to analyze it or
break it down it just doesn't make
anything off
[Music]
Dave operating spins back from the top
of that screen and hits a three-point
shot Oh boys in on how easy the handle
is the wall hand
that game against Brooklyn yeah name
into the label see what
the glass he's got 42 tonight naked
40-point handling the basketball venison
look at him go away from the SAP lock
and he's reading from the shot block in
the left arm with Allen as is going up
14 of 20 from the field 6 of 10 for 3
coming off the screen
bounce game
step back yes sir Lillard 46 on the
night and even on a some missus that's
created those easy rethought and
opportunities for his teammates they've
opted to screen beers in left to right
to land up but in lasers a chance to
take bold Davian hesitates down drives
it and laid it in with a left hand
what a blazes to set this thing down
leave an eight-oh campaign for the nets
to take a five-point lead nice lob
inside Simon took grab it in one motion
and lay at home
as it did when he tried to attached with
AfriNIC watch the trails go to the rim
mothered five assists tonight
here comes Kyrie down on the lane delay
it up a ten and a foul
[Applause]
look out as the Blazers bringing it
bounce Bazemore look sister Lillard
coming to the ball attacks the body of
Ty restore it with a little looper to
three with only two or three seconds off
the clock that's the way it's got to be
stopped by returning into the lane step
back banker up it in
that's lead is at five with 17 seconds
left they'll bring it up in the front
court near their own [ __ ] that's just a
great move it does a great job but that
terrific with a change of pace at thee
but they work his way up the floor and
score the three
which gives us six people a loss for the
Blazers as he comes down and cranks the
triple what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content